Je pense qu'on devrait sans doute être un peu plus disposés
à contempler le magnifique spectacle d'un rayon de soleil
transperçant les nuages, et se dire alors : "Attends un peu,
on dirait deux chats qui dansent la salsa ! »
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
Ou, à la vue de ce grand nuage blanc et moelleux
au dessus du centre commercial, se dire : "On dirait
l'Abominable Homme des Neiges qui va braquer une banque. »
(Rires)
Ils sont l'équivalent naturel de ces tâches d'encre,
vous savez, que les psys montraient à leur patients
dans les années 60,
et je crois que si vous faisiez attention aux formes que vous voyez dans les nuages,
ça vous ferait économiser sur vos frais de psychanalyse.
Supposons que vous soyez amoureux. D'accord ?
Vous levez les yeux, et qu'est-ce que vous voyez ?
Pas vrai ? Ou alors c'est le contraire.
Votre partenaire vient de vous larguer,
et partout où vous allez, vous ne voyez que des couples qui s'embrassent.
(Rires)
Imaginons que vous traversez une période d'angoisse existentielle.
Vous savez, vous pensez à votre propre mortalité.
Et qui voyez-vous à l'horizon ? La Grande Faucheuse.
(Rires)
Ou bien une femme qui prend un bain de soleil topless.
Qu'est-ce que ça peut bien vouloir dire ?
Qu'est-ce que ça peut bien vouloir dire ? Je n'en ai aucune idée.
Mais ce dont je suis sûr, c'est que
la mauvaise réputation des nuages est complètement injuste.
Je pense qu'on devrait défendre leur réputation,
et c'est pourquoi j'ai créé, il y a quelques années,
la Cloud Appreciation Society.
Nous avons aujourd'hui des dizaines de milliers de membres
dans presque cent pays.
Et toutes les photos que je vous ai montrées
ont été envoyées par des membres de la société.
Cette société est là, pour rappeler ceci :
Il ne faut pas se plaindre des nuages.
Bien au contraire. Ils sont, en fait,
l'image de la nature la plus variée, la plus évocatrice, et poétique.
Je crois que si vous avez la tête dans les nuages,
de temps à autres, ça vous aide à garder les pieds sur terre.
Je vais vous montrer pourquoi, avec l'aide de quelques uns
de mes types de nuages préférés.
Commençons par celui-ci. Le cirrus,
qui tient son nom du mot latin désignant une boucle de cheveux.
Il est formé entièrement de cristaux de glace
qui dégringolent des couches supérieures de la troposphère.
Durant leur chute,
ils traversent plusieurs couches, avec des vents différents,
qui les font accélérer et ralentir,
ce qui donne au nuage cette apparence de coups de pinceau,
des coups de pinceau que l'on appelle traînées.
Les vents à cette altitude peuvent être très, très violents.
Leur vitesse peut atteindre 400, 500 kilomètres-heure.
Ces nuages foncent à toute vitesse,
mais vus de tout en bas,
ils ont l'air de se mouvoir tout en douceur et avec grâce,
comme la plupart des nuages.
C’est pour cela que contempler les nuages, c'est ralentir,
retrouver son calme.
C'est comme une petit moment de méditation quotidienne.
Ces nuages sont très communs.
Qu'en est-il des plus rares, comme le nuage lenticulaire,
en forme d'OVNI ?
Ces nuages se forment dans les régions montagneuses.
Quand le vent s'élève pour franchir une montagne,
il peut prendre une trajectoire en forme de vague en aval du sommet,
avec ces nuages qui planent
à la crête de ces ondes stationnaires invisibles,
en forme de soucoupes volantes.
D’ailleurs, certaines des premières photos d’OVNIs en noir et blanc
sont en fait des nuages lenticulaires. C’est véridique.
Un peu plus rares sont les nuages "punch-hole". Non ?
C'est quand une couche est constituée de gouttelettes d'eau très, très froides,
et à un endroit elles commencent à geler,
et cette congélation déclenche une réaction en chaîne concentrique
avec les cristaux de glace qui tombent en cascade,
en prenant l'apparence de tentacules de méduse.
Encore plus rare, le nuage de Kelvin-Helmholtz.
Pas très élégant, comme nom. Il aurait besoin d'être rebaptisé.
Ça ressemble à une série de vagues qui se brisent,
et c'est provoqué par le cisaillement de deux vents :
le vent au dessus de la couche de nuages, et celui du dessous
différent sensiblement, et au milieu, entre les deux,
on obtient cette ondulation de l'air,
et si la différence de vitesse entre les vents est pile la bonne,
le sommet des ondulations s'enroule
pour former ces magnifiques tourbillons en forme de vagues.
Bon. Ces nuages sont plus rares que les cirrus,
mais ils ne sont pas si rares que ça.
Si vous levez les yeux, et que vous faites attention au ciel,
vous en verrez un jour ou l'autre,
peut être pas aussi spectaculaires que ceux là, mais vous en verrez.
Et vous en verrez près de chez vous.
Les nuages sont l'un des spectacles naturels
les plus égalitaires, car nous avons tous
une vue fantastique du ciel.
Et ces nuages, ces nuages plus rares,
nous rappellent que l'on peut toujours trouver de l'exotisme dans notre quotidien.
Il n'y a pas plus enrichissant et stimulant
pour un esprit actif et curieux que d'être surpris, d'être émerveillé.
C'est pour ça que nous sommes tous là, à TED, non ?
Mais il n'est pas nécessaire de se précipiter
à l'autre bout du monde, loin de son environnement familier,
pour être surpris.
Il vous suffit simplement de faire un pas dehors,
d'être attentif à ce qui est tellement ordinaire, tellement banal,
tellement familier que personne d'autre ne le remarque.
Voici un nuage qui passe rarement inaperçu :
le cumulonimbus, le nuage d’orage.
C'est celui qui provoque le tonnerre, les éclairs et la grêle.
Ces nuages se déploient à la manière d'une énorme enclume
qui s'élève jusqu'à 15 kilomètres dans l'atmosphère.
Ils sont l'expression de l'imposante architecture
de notre atmosphère.
Mais vus du sol, ils incarnent
la puissance des forces élémentaires
qui régissent notre atmosphère.
En face de cela, sous la pluie battante et la grêle,
on éprouve un sentiment de connexion avec notre atmosphère.
Ça nous rappelle que nous sommes des créatures
qui habitent dans cet océan d'air.
On ne vit pas sous le ciel. On vit dedans.
Et il me semble que ce sentiment viscéral de connexion avec notre atmosphère
est un antidote.
C'est un antidote contre notre tendance de plus en plus fréquente
à considérer que l'on peut connaître le monde
en regardant un écran d'ordinateur, vous savez,
quand on est dans une zone qui capte le wi-fi.
Mais le nuage qui montre le mieux
pourquoi la chasse aux nuages n'a jamais été aussi précieuse qu'aujourd'hui,
c'est celui-ci, le cumulus.
Pas vrai ? Il se forme quand il y a du soleil.
Quand vous fermez les yeux et imaginez un nuage,
c'est probablement l'un de ceux-là qui vous vient à l'esprit.
Tous les formes dans les nuages que je vous ai montrées au début,
étaient des cumulus.
On peut facilement y deviner des formes,
car ils ont des contours nets et précis.
Ça nous rappelle
que la chasse aux nuages n'a pas de but précis,
à quel point c'est une activité sans but.
Evidemment, ce n'est pas en vous allongeant sur le dos
et en contemplant le ciel que vous allez changer le monde.
C'est inutile. C'est une activité inutile,
et c'est précisément ce qui la rend si importante.
Le monde numérique s’arrange toujours pour nous donner l'impression
d'être débordés en permanence.
Vous voyez de quoi je parle. En plus de devoir répondre
à l'obligation ancestrale de gagner sa vie,
de faire bouillir la marmite, d'élever une famille,
d'écrire des lettres de remerciements,
on doit maintenant se débrouiller
pour répondre à une montagne d'emails en retard,
mettre à jour une page Facebook,
ou alimenter un compte Twitter.
La chasse aux nuages est une bonne excuse pour ne rien faire.
(Rires)
Et parfois on a besoin...
(Applaudissements)
Parfois on a besoin d'excuses pour ne rien faire.
On a besoin
que ces grandes divinités des hommes oisifs
nous rappellent que ralentir,
saisir l'instant présent, sans se préoccuper
des choses que l'on doit faire ou que l'on aurait dû faire,
juste être là, à laisser notre imagination
nous affranchir de nos soucis quotidiens
et à vivre le moment présent, c'est bon pour nous,
c'est bon pour le moral.
C'est bon pour l'inventivité. C'est bon pour la créativité.
C'est bon pour l’âme.
Donc,continuez à lever les yeux,
à vous émerveiller devant les beautés éphémères,
et souvenez-vous toujours de vivre en gardant la tête dans les nuages.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)